so you typically as the man who is known
to have a plan no you're never stopping
out with the plan I need a writer to
write it down for me so yeah so you do
you relate to your character in any
aspect other than that yeah I guess so
yeah I mean I am a dad so and it's some
really funny stuff happens in as a
parent you know that I'm sure any parent
can relate to kids say some of the
craziest things and um you know we try
to capture some of that on the show yeah
I think the the concept for the show I
wanted to do something I wanted to play
a parent and I think I am I want to play
a husband and a dad that's what I was
looking to do and I met with Jeff and
Jackie Phil go and they had an
interesting experience they you know
they have kids and they were both
working and they had nannies and stuff
and they decided you know what let's
take a year off they're feeling a little
disconnected and we're gonna move take
the kids
no nannies we're gonna move to Paris for
a year they quit their jobs and they
went to Paris for a year
and they get there and they really they
realize spending all day every day with
their kids their kids are like horrible
people at a restaurant picked up mashed
potatoes with their hands even with
their hands and stuff so they they
thought there's a there's a show in here
somewhere so that sort of started the
ball rolling and they come up with the
concept for this what was what was that
thought process like for you coming back
to do you know sitcom - I know you've
done episodes obviously and obviously
friends but huh but was it a tough
decision
locking back in to do a sitcom again in
day to day well you know episodes kind
of wet my whistle for work because I had
taken about six years off five to Joy
five or six years something like that I
kind of lost count and I got a call from
David Crane Jeffrey klarik to come and
they said they had an idea for a show
and I said absolutely I'm in and they
said you want to hear the idea and I
said oh okay sure I guess I was smart
but I'd so much trust in them and we
went and we made episodes and it was we
did nine episodes every 18 months which
is not a grueling schedule and you know
over the five years that we do I guess
four year which we've done we just
finished our fifth season but at they're
still going into the fourth season
it's kind of like I want to work more I
want to work more now that I'm back in
it and I remember how much I loved
working so I wanted to do more of it so
I talked with my team and we sort of
said okay well let's try to put together
let's put together a show and met with
writers and here we are and I want to
come back to a multicam show because
that if I'm gonna do a full season of 22
you know hopefully it's a multicam show
you're home for dinner every night and
as a parent you know I'm not working 14
16 18 hour days you know go in at a
decent time and come home you know when
she's home from school that kind of
thing we had dinner together and helped
over the homework and so it's like I can
I'm still involved with my family so
it's kind of the best of both worlds and
also you with a sitcom you're not
shooting out of order like a single
camera show you know you rehearse all
week and you're tightening the scripts
and they rewrite and you're discussing
the structure of the story and does this
work is this clear enough there's that
to clear do we need to maybe not hit
that one on the head so much and it kind
of it evolves the story to its best form
by Friday night and then you go out in
front of the crowd and you shoot it like
a play so it's in chronological order so
you know something that you find in
front of the crowd and the first scene
you can maybe call back later the
writers are all present and you know
it's this sort of evolving living thing
on Friday night in front of the crowd
and it's always a magical night I
remember that from friends I was it was
great it was really a fun process and
yeah
I think it's just a piece of lint so
you're able to then make it home in sing
Rihanna with your daughter we hear she's
a Rihanna fishy Rihanna Lady Gaga Taylor
Swift's and I'm down with all that stuff
are you
is it worrisome at all if she's around
the household singing out like I have my
money in some of the lyrics Rihanna yes
she won't know we have a swear jar at
the house what's the penalty you got to
put a buck in there if she says she does
she's not allowed to use the language
okay even if it's in a Rihanna song
that's playing as a poor not necessarily
only Rihanna wanna pick on Rio yeah when
those come up she leaves she omits that
for a song so she's a good girl okay yes
amazing she says she's on your best bit
well that's what I'm in the room I don't
know everyone I'm not there when she's
up in her room alone she might be just
swearing enough so does that mean she
because we also saw that she would like
Rihanna and Amy to play her birthday
party yeah is that happening yeah well I
took her know that February 30 year you
are but we went I took her to see Taylor
Swift at the Staples Center and um Chris
Rock was in the greenroom with his two
girls to meet to meet Taylor and I got
through my publicist hooked it up so I
could go and meet Taylor and my daughter
could meet Taylor and she came out she
was super gracious and spent time with
the kids and then ask Kristen I would
come up on stage oh it's anything her
Chris Rock I like and then look at the
kids and they're like yeah so he and I
end up going going up on stage and
walking down the catwalk like to
complete boneheads
he's really funny and then I got to the
end when my daughter was there and it
was Taylor's mother watching my daughter
while I went up on stage it was the
whole thing was surreal so that was my
rock star moment and uh
I get to the end of the stage and I
looked down and there she is just like
bright and I look at my dad up there so
then the next morning at breakfast
having breakfast a nice like just
thinking how am I gonna bring go so
would you think your dad I'm here on
stage with Taylor Swift last lunch
without missing a beat she goes I
thought your kind of cheesy
you just can't wait you can't wait